what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be talking about why
i don't fit the mold of a traditional
woman
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
okay so i have never
felt like i'm like a traditional woman
woman that we see all the time
on the channel right or that like i'll
see
men talking about they always want i
have literally never felt like i fit
that mold
um and let me tell you why
i've never wanted to be a housewife and
i'm not saying like i wouldn't want to
stay home maybe like when i just had
kids like you know five and under
maybe but i i get a lot of
pride and like value from like a day's
work and i love working
and i want to have kids i want to do
that but i've never
like the dream for me has never been to
marry rich it's never been
to be like a traditional housewife
um and i never really cared that much
about
income so it's just interesting to me
because
hearing like what guys want um i
i mean there's some boxes i fit some i
don't but that's just one
that i definitely don't another box that
um kevin samuels like talks a lot about
on his show
um is women that don't talk a lot
and when he said this i'm like i'm like
the most extroverted talkative like
i'm i like to chit chat you know chit
chat
and it's just funny because um i could
totally see like why guys like that
and why like men that really push like
the traditional roles and stuff like
that but
yeah it's just not me and
i was just thinking about this the other
day anyways um that's like my two minute
video for the day don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell i'll talk to
you guys next time